[Music]
in the winter they're moving down
because the glacier is warmer than the
air temperature
ice worms navigate through tiny ice
cracks to find ideal conditions within
the glacier they could be anywhere even
at the bottom of a giant crevasse prime
ice worm habitat but dangerous grounds
for humans the walls are 50 feet high
the snow around the edge of a crevasse
can be highly unstable
I don't want anybody's getting really
age unless we know it's a checked safe
spot at least ten people have fallen
into crevices in Denali and died it is
possible I don't like it it's very
inconsistent I fell up to my waist a
couple of times in it I've been up to
this thing a rare view from inside a
glacier
a lot of times they'll just be on the
surface
um but they're quite remarkably they're
able to penetrate high-density ice here
quite amazing they can get in ladies
I don't see any nature's ready-made hold
is a bust
to find ice worms they'll have to change
tech they head back to where the pilot
first spotted ice ones to dig through
the snow that covers the glacier
they dig
empty how deep are you dear
ya know 20 feet into the snow
I don't know where the heck those worms
are here's the up this looks like the
fern fertilizer yeah
so we're good two feet below the fern
one this half inch line of compacted
dirt and ice marks the snow that fell
since summer
it shows Dan that ten feet has fallen
here in just a few weeks you'd figure
we'd picked just the year to try to do
this when they got the most stuff
somewhere out here millions of ice ones
move silently through the ice but too
much snow has buried the worms the only
option try again next year we dug the
steeper so he could go and they seem to
be deeper than that
they're here but they're smarter than we
give them credit for her thing I'll be
back